so Stephen is the mic working okay yep
especially I'm talking about alcohol
Gary just let us know when you walk in
okay thank you I'm not sure how much are
capable of today
sorry
now Gary I got about 15 sarees I can't
come today this morning I'm sick my dog
has the flu
I'm here
powerpoint slide you're good and then
the audio will come on so I mean just
connect your end of this call because
get feedback and then we'll use the same
number again when the presentation is
over we'll die you into this number okay
Gary all right thanks for your patience
okay oh yeah
okay welcome everyone as you probably
know today is Dion's PhD dissertation
defense it's always exciting time and I
know that she's been working hard and I
think we'll all be looking forward to it
as usual we'll do the usual procedure
where she'll give her presentation the
public will ask questions then the
public will be excused leaving her and
her committee and then she'll be excused
and the committee will render their
final judgment that's put any pressure
that's put any pressure on her anyways
it's it's been a long road and and Dan's
been here for a while and it's always
fun to see people reach these milestones
let me just give a brief introduction I
know that most of you know her but she
received her bachelor's degree from UC
Irvine with the double major in
economics and mathematics and then
received her MBA from a French
institution whose only acronym I'll
pronounce which is I nscad and then she
received a master of science in nursing
and advanced registered nurse
practitioner degree from Seattle
University where she had some other jobs
along the way also ended up teaching
there and other doing other work around
the Puget Sound area and then she joined
our program as PhD student and as if all
of this is not enough she's also been
spending time working as a clinician as
a nurse practitioner at old town clinic
which is a clinic for the underserved in
Portland so I will
it over to the end Thank You belt thank
you all for coming I'm delighted to see
you here and I'm delighted to be able to
talk about the work I've done as bill
said over the last forty three months so
but who's counting it started with a
term paper and Bill 610 class you know
introduction to buy off romantics and
I've gotten the tremendous about the
help along the way and I'm very grateful
in March of 2011 I met with a lot of you
we did a presentations online you can
find it on the onion dramatics blog
where I talked about my lit review
behind this this work in January of 2012
I presented my methods you could find
that also in informatics today I'm going
to focus more on methods and the results
that came from them it's only 40 minutes
I would really like to have an
interactive talk but I've got a lot to
cover so I'm going to ask you hold your
questions to the end it's okay with you
so when I talk to you before I mentioned
that there were some really key drivers
that are changing we do in health care
particularly in primary care and those
key drivers are the rising prevalence of
chronic disease is resulting in a change
in the requirements for health care we
are having more visits and these visits
are requiring more special whoa more
specialized skills so all of a sudden
it's beyond what one provider can do
we're overloading the system so we're
having to work more in teams and
increasingly the EHR is becoming an
important part of supporting that work
to try and achieve the Triple Aim this
collaboration needs to take place not
only in the primary care clinic which is
being redone as the patient-centered
medical home but it needs to be done
within them all right dr. Gorman
delighted to see you being done with in
the neighborhood in other words we need
to improve the collaboration not just on
a team basis within the clinic but with
the specials that are outside the clinic
and I think that's an important area
that's been understudied one of the
things the sperm is wonderful because
every has to walk in the front I love it
come on in Talara one of the things that
kind of bears in mind are reinforces
what I told you two years ago is that a
major effort that's going on by CMS the
people that bring you Medicare is called
the comprehensive primary care
initiative and what that is it's a large
demonstration project over 300,000
Medicare recipients in seven states
designed around implementing and trying
to improve the effectiveness of the
patient-centered medical home these
clinics are getting additional payments
that are not fee based but are rather
based upon the people they're taken care
of and to be in this program they had to
meet some requirements they had to
provide 24-hour medical care guided by
the medical record like the sea do that
with a paper chart they had to provide
population based approach with care
teams and managers responsible and if it
team approach looking at the overall
panel team-based care and it had to
provide coordination of care across that
medical neighborhood with the primary
care provider PCP is primary care
providers lead with clear mechanisms for
data interchange sound like another role
for health information technology we
talked about two years ago is happening
today
the interaction of the electronic health
record in collaboration has been
understudied we've got some good
formative work I mean Joe Nash here's
has has done a lot of it unintended
consequences it's a concept that comes
from system theory that when you
implement a system it's going to have
consequences you could not predict good
or bad and if they're surrounding
systems and she and others have done
some excellent work in this area Kawara
as early as 2,000 actually looked at
using the EHR as a communication vehicle
and his conclusion was there are times
that sometimes it just gotta talk you
can't look at the computer replace all
communications it's not a rich enough
channel their work on the interaction is
just beginning to emerge notable work is
work done by a we're mb Hammond and the
group that's been working with focus
groups at ba sites around the country
and they've done qualitative work that
has taken a look at how use of the HR is
increased common ground that basis of
Understanding between clinicians that it
has in some cases exacerbated tensions
between roles particularly between
management and providers can all of a
sudden managers are able to see better
and critique providers and also that the
EHRs performance issues quality of data
miscommunications actually have negative
effects on collaboration behaviors
Jordan lamb ham did a study in a large
health system in Texas where she looked
at HR in communication and her
conclusion is that even though they had
one HR different providers and different
practices had very different
communication patterns with widely
varying degrees of effectiveness just
having an EHR doesn't assure a common
communication system
very little work on quantitative effects
of the HR one thing I found from
Mathematica is part of an overall study
of the effect of the effects of the HR
was they said that in a position of
survey they found that providers
believed that use of the HR improved
their communications not within the
clinic no change there do with people
outside the clinic one of the reasons we
may be having difficulties getting the
quantitative data is that we don't have
very good instruments for measuring
across the boundaries within it without
the clinic there's an article in press
that's been accepted for publication in
medical care by Valentine that actually
looks at the surveys we have available
to look at collaboration in health care
and to see which ones are validated and
will work across the clinic boundaries
she found two she found one by college
that she focuses on nurses looks like vs
team work across boundaries and she
found a second one by jody Hoffer
cattell that looks at relational
coordination and that's actually a
combination of communication and trust
and respect goals sharing and what about
come try to remember okay but good in
goal sharing and it's a basically an
overall trust measure and a
communication measure there are other
tools I mean of AHRQ put out Nablus
300-page doubtless all different kinds
of coordination tools she looked around
they weren't valid one of the tools then
there's one by Judith bags who's here at
ohsu and Jews was could have spent some
time with me talking to you about her
measure and she's got a measure that she
developed it looked at nurses in the ICU
and how they work with physicians good
study doesn't work in the setting Ron
stock has a team development measure
that focuses on how
teams are working together within the
clinic and here we've got a difference
because this is a survey that focuses a
lot on the Addis antecedent the
behaviors and situations that make
people more collaborative rather than
the actual collaborative behavior and
finally Gary also was good enough to
sheriff me his collaboration wizard
where he actually was working on that
distance problem how you collaborate
across distance for researchers and it
was based upon a common ground model you
know once again look at the other
seasons so there are instrum so there I
was able to look at but nothing quite
that what i wanted so i ended up with
three research questions when we talking
about today first of all is to try and
understand the broad framework how does
the HR affect the way clinicians work
together by collisions I mean people who
can change care plans and this was
actually qualitative so they trying to
look at the big picture how can we
measure collaboration behaviors
behaviors not the other seasons within
out the clinic and finally can we
quantitatively take a look at the
effects of increases in the use of the
HR and other communication channels on
collaboration behaviors those are my
three questions
so three questions three phases the
first phase was a broad overview look
trying to in an unbiased way get an idea
of the field understand some of the
things that are going on between
collaboration and the HR I've been lucky
enough to be part of the poet team for
the past three years hitter by Joe Nash
and the poet team was given the
assignment by the office of the National
quarter for a chai tea to develop
guidelines for the safe usage of the
electronic health record as part of that
we got to go to five different sites
around the countries that it's
successfully implemented the ahr we did
a lot of things but among the things we
did I got to take part of 49 interviews
where we asked questions based on an
open-ended strength semi structured
questionnaire I developed about
collaboration behaviors in the HR I and
others loan team also got to spend 60
hours of field observation watching
people use the HR providers you see HR
and their collaboration that way and
I'll talk more about the analysis
methods in just a minute Keane phase 2
we actually worked to answer that
question can we develop a measure by
developing an instrument here at ohsu
both within the department and within
the GIM clinic and then once we had it
developed then we went to validate it at
a clinic here important and in the third
phase was actually more of an
application can we apply this to try and
look at what channels are working in
this phase David door was kind enough
and it's taught that team to work was be
in and topped out by the V stands for
transforming outcomes for patients
through medical home evaluation and
redesigned at I get a right pretty close
okay so and so
got to go to eight clinics using four
different EHRs widely different sizes
throughout Oregon they're all but the
common dinner was there all committing
the patient-centered medical home so
collaboration would be an interest to
them and this was a purely quantitative
survey effort so looking at the first
phase or aim how does the EHR affect
collaboration providers there's a
challenge here we all and probably me
especially bring to our work diocese we
have preconceived notions there are
things we've read how do we try and set
them aside and get an unbiased view and
what's going on well one thing and I had
a tough project leader dr. Ashe who
insisted we right by Wright biasing
mammals before I did my work okay so be
aware what you've got and try and guard
against it second is working as a team
is helpful our team had people from all
different disciplines and a lot of
different viewpoints people who weren't
afraid to speak out when they disagreed
so that was a very valuable part of the
exercise and then the way we collect the
data using open-ended questions
recording the transcripts and I will
talk about the singing the way we
analyze the data once again try to guard
against biases and the extent possible
we did grounded theory analysis and you
know I've red blazer and Strauss and
Strauss in Corbin and I would argue that
you can never be completely grounded
you're always bringing something to it
but we try to be where possible start
from ground up which meant that we did
ethnographic data collection at the
beginning and then we did exit
interviews with the key informants to
verify we found on our way out then once
we have the data transcribed to analysts
myself and jennifer hall who's curling
to the proper family medicine separately
coated the data and then we met to
reconcile at the form of the codebook
we did this after each set of
transcripts came in then once we had our
coding results we condense them and I we
can be in an expert panel we actually
give you the panel twice to try and
review that panel and develop the themes
from that work and the themes that came
up were that there were four roles for
the HR was one of the ones we came up
with one of the roles is the original
role for the EHR the HR wasn't
originally intended as a repository it's
where all the data goes where you can
find everything hope you find it may be
harder times and others the second rule
is that of a messenger and if you read
like Larry weed on the paper chart the
idea behind the paper chart was it was
supposed to support communication it
wasn't a communication channel there was
no intent that I would send my channel
my progress in it across the street it
arrived provide the basis for me doing a
letter or report we talked to clinicians
however one common thing they'd say is
oh I communicate with that other person
by sending them a copy of my progress
code ok so it's become a channel it a
little bit more than we originally
anticipated for the HR to do but the HR
has changed even more than the day
burchardt when you think about the way
we set up templates templates and their
own way to prescribe the workflow and
who does what that the n make and there
the vitals and a provider doesn't the
fact that a provider can has to enter
the diagnosis of the orders it describes
the workflow start silks structure the
work itself in the collaboration but
it's more than that as we've developed
computerized provider order entry we're
getting some pretty sophisticated
algorithms that define who does what win
much more explicitly and they're even
bundles like warmer ones people we
talked to have a bundle for diabetes
that would issue
four hundred orders over a six-month
period based upon assigning a diagnosis
of diabetes type 2 in a goal of eight
percent a1c they arranged from getting
lab exams to actually having an
endocrinology follow-up if they weren't
one target in the six months authorized
by the fact that the provider said
problem diabetes too a1c goal eight
percent i authorize protocol it's become
the orchestrated making sure the right
person is the right thing at the right
time and finally it's a monitor with the
HR were able to create registries and
track people how people are doing on
conditions we're also able to create
dashboards so teens can see how they're
doing you know reading they're doing
good rather having problems maybe a
yellow they're not but that dashboards
are commonly shared between members the
team solves it we've got a monitor it
says how we're doing and a little less
helpful sometimes as we're also getting
the results up to the change of clinic
leadership and management that can
create some tension these behaviors map
directly these gisby roles map directly
to collaboration behaviors how well we
do the documentation how well we put
stuff the repository I'll find a bullet
is affects directly trust respect how
well we do the messenger affects
communication the orchestrator affects
how well we can coordinate in the
monitor can affect how well we can
tailor solutions how will we can adapt
what we do to feed specific needs for
example some comments we got on the
repository trust or inspect bearing is
everybody said it's great it's all there
may not be able to find it but it's all
there okay they told us that occasion
they were problems big complaint we've
got was on the copy and paste function
one case we were looking at a very long
note
and a very frustrated clinician who said
everything this note is either
fabrication is correct two years ago but
not today cut and paste can promote
errors that occur for a long time and on
the other side a sea mio told us you
know that's not new we just have more
visibility people who wrote good notes
in the paper are still write good notes
in electronic error it just is more
visible now as a messenger function a
podiatrist the community health center
said it's great all I have to do is
write a brief note attached my EHR
progress note and Senate provider it's
really quick much better than trying to
call or write and it can also increase
this cognitive awareness looking at
nurses we know the attending is checking
the vitals even though he's not in the
room and we know he'll come when these
two gives us a way to start doing some
distributed cognitive awareness Nathan
okay but there's a some contraries and
one of them we heard in several places
was that when you implement an EHR
people can forget that they can talk to
each other they called it brain freeze
they said we put the h RN and then three
months later we had to go back into your
retraining and tell people yes you can
still pick a proponent call we talked
about the value of using bundles one
system we talked to us that they're
actually using a preventive care bundle
for two hundred and twenty thousand
patients to automatically order things
like pap screens or a 1c they talked
about using the EHR and its associated
tools to try and make sure they've got
the right person doing the right thing
at the right time that's often related
to having people working at the top of
their license one of the problems we
heard is these are great tools but they
can take time to do and as one person
told us you can have a great tool for
asthma
but if it takes some 10 minutes to do it
isn't going to happen providers just
don't have the time and a 15 to
20-minute visit to do it sorry and
finally on the look for the monitor
function it can drive adaptation if you
show relative measures people see
there's a problem and they can work to
try and fix it they can change their
workflow they can change their approach
to patient one issue is trying to make
sure that your goals are perceived as
valid a place we looked at was paying
incentives off of their performance of
the age measure the HR paid incentives
if it was below six seven percent but at
seven percent they didn't pay an
incentive that was perceived as me maybe
not to credible and cause some
discontent so overall we found that the
EHR was an important actor in
collaboration processes that the roles
tied to collaboration behaviors that
health care collaboration was not a
single behavior but with several and
finally that the each artist performs in
one roll can have some trickle-down
effects on performance in other areas
the second question was can we develop a
generalized tool to measure health care
collaboration behaviors and it was
important to be generalized because the
rules are changing in health care people
are doing things they didn't do
especially is ten years ago we wanted to
be brief warming school that was we
found in our process it's really hard to
get providers doing it takes over about
five minutes to do we want to be valid
for both co-located distant
collaborations reliable profession
neutral we want to have both paper and
online versions depending upon what the
clinic work of the clinic and we want it
to be focused on behaviors not on the
antecedents of behaviors this is not
necessarily be a standalone survey but
one to say here's what is going on so
you can measure validity a lot of
different ways face content convergent
construct and criterion the Ballantine
article so that most people only show
two or three of those we're actually
trying to show five one of which has
actually come to come the last one
criterion is going to come in faith in
our next phase we also want to look at
reliability we have a bias for example
between the online the paper versions
are the fact is homogeneous in other
words that we talk look at the things
we're saying we're measured are they all
measuring the same thing really
measuring different things and finally
is a reliable how much the variance is
being captured by instantly using so the
process we had was our original draft
was based upon the formative work needed
the work we did in the safer project it
was based upon theory and the theory I
actually drew a lot from salads Clancy
and Kidman and like and also reviewed
with kissing instruments based on Wii
and then Dave actually helped me here
develop the draft instrument which we
then when we test it we start off by
testing it with seven people here within
the department providers
which is who the department based upon
that Congress with Nielsen suggested we
actually stopped rebuys it we did it and
rolls out again with another seven this
time out the GM clinic that gave us an
instrument that looked fairly good we
took it to the GIM group the research in
progress group and we got three pages of
comments and thank enough for taking
those comments on the clinic we
reflected that and then we took it to an
expert panel who did a delphi process of
looking at it first then commenting and
then bring it all together to try and
make sure that we had content validity
that we actually covered the waterfront
but our domain was questions are
applicable to the mains we said when we
cover the domain the resulting tool is a
is an instrument rather has two parts
because we want to also look at the
application the first part instrument
looks at collaboration behaviors the
second looks at communication channel
use frequency both are gesture scales
like glickert scale and we asked
participants to rate the frequency of
the behavior on a scale from one to nine
where one was never and I'm was always
by was sometimes we also gave them a
tenth option don't know which we then
coded in our data analysis as missing
data we didn't try to impute there
okay looking at the administration we
solicited 21 of the 21 questions that
were in the clinic the time for a
validation study they all participated
one of whom did not do the online
version so we actually got 41 surveys
back each survey had two collaborations
we actually get it got the rating on 82
collaborations each survey and I should
have been sittin before backup you can
see the other thing it does is we
actually asked them to break both a
co-located equal to your last coat
significant co-located collaboration and
your last significant collaboration with
an outside professional so we got two
per survey instrument thank ok ence of
the 82 14 were test retest take the same
collaboration and do it and 68 were
unique ok now the statisticians on the
group I'm sure are going uh you can't do
that you're getting four responses from
the same person the data is not
independent okay well yeah that's right
so we had to do something different
there are two ways to approach one is to
look at it in terms of multi-level
analysis and that case what we do is we
said that the data is clustered we had
groups of four and one of two and we
tried to do is we actually try to break
it down into the actual observation they
gave us like they might rate it a seven
and then there was a true response plus
an individual bias you know the way some
people will always ask them how they're
doing they go great and some people go
it's okay individual bias same day
different observer by getting multiple
observations we're able to estimate a
correction factor for that using
multi-level analysis okay as an
alternative a different way to handle
the same problem what you can do is you
can actually calculate how much that
clustering changes by looking at the
intraclass correlation
and you can inflate your estimated
variance which makes it harder to show
the your hypothesis are true and use
that we actually use both techniques in
this this process the other technique we
used was we use structural equation
modeling what this does is there allows
us to describe the system in terms of
equations and evaluate them all
simultaneously using a maximum
likelihood estimator and the advantage
this is not just that it allows us to
look at the whole thing all together but
it also gives statistics for the fit of
our model how well does the overall
model work as opposed just looking at
piece by piece so you know basically we
have four factors trust communication
coordination and adaptation in this case
I'm showing it based upon eight
questions some of the questions were
reversed scored rather than asking how
often do you communicate effectively
we'd ask how often do you not give you
get effectively which means we had to
reverse the answers that's BS or screens
and what we found is if you're looking
at how the responses are related how
much it as the factors are that within
the factors we had good relationships
our cronbach's alpha you can see was
between points 7.8 but if we tried to
add them together into a scale it fell
2.31 would suggests like we had in our
formative work collaboration or
different behaviors
we took a look at the results of a club
co-located versus distance results and
we found co-located scores were higher
than distance this isn't a shock this is
something we knew all along but what it
does is it shows that at least in this
respect the scale seems to be working
this is called convergent validity my
original assumption the construct I was
working on was that this was a what's
called a gov'ment scale that you've had
a series of behaviors trust
communication coordination adaptation
and you needed to have trust before you
can do communication you need to have
communication before you could do
coordination you need equation for
adaptation the way you test that is by
looking at the coefficient of
reproducibility which says how often is
the frequency of one behavior a lower
level behavior higher than higher
behavior and the standard is usually you
want to be above point eight five didn't
make it you can see if you look at it
actually coordination adaptation was
point 51 basically flip the coin so I
had to drop that one but we did find as
the factors are related that okay and
the trust either by the way we had was
skewed positively so i had to youtube in
the data into sometimes trust or less to
usually trust and always trust two three
categories because it wasn't normally
distributed but being in the upper
category of the trust scale meant that
on average you were one point four steps
higher in the communication scale for
every step you increased in the
communication scale
you could expect to go point 29 steps of
the coordination scale and for every
step in the coordination scale you can
expect to go up point 49 the adaptation
scale so there is a relationship it is
significant in depew to a level if you
look at the model overall it's got a
Ramsey rmsea of 0.45 which is considered
good put one is considered acceptable
although it did none of the overall
variance it explains is not that great
it's point 25 and you'd actually want to
have more so there are other things
going on besides this but the model
seems to work strong hypothesis koopman
scale no weak hypothesis these factors
are related yes okay just some other
results it was fairly brief warnings
that took the most time was we had
open-ended questions those took about a
minute from the zoo without those it was
under a five minute scale it's
generalizable everybody agreed that you
could use it everybody involved in
planning care we tried it later on to
use it for mas it didn't work for
enemies they about half of them couldn't
complete it and the ones that did the
psychometric properties were terrible it
was reliable split half mean difference
was was pretty low point zero twenty
percent good cross between the split
halves cronbach's alpha we talked about
reliability 0.65 25 sets within
acceptable range and paper online
versions bias less than point one
percent so pretty good that way and we
talked about face validity because
that's where we got we're talking to the
participants we did the development
content luma our expert panel convergent
our distance versus co-located and
construct which is showing there is a
model supports what we're doing we
quantitatively show that criteria will
talk about in just a minute
I've got two mice we also had open-ended
questions and was interesting to me with
the open-ended questions came out pretty
uniform distance time the HR factors
being co-located it's a big helper
collaboration time is a barrier to
collaboration and the ahr helps ok this
is novel I haven't seen a scale that
actually looks a tad apt ation in
specific behavior and behaviors purely
rather behaviors than as he it's because
most people have a theory about what's
going to fix it they also want to do
that I didn't do that this is not an
insolent you can apply it and give it
once an applied to an individual it
takes repeated measurements remember
each one is just a snapshot and so it
takes repeated measurements to try and
get about aggregation but I think it can
be useful for groups in managing it
monitoring the effects of an
intervention but you got to keep in mind
higher collaboration that may or may not
be useful different behaviors the
question is what what could be most
helpful
okay phase three question was how
disease of the HR and other
communication channels if that
collaboration behaviors here we use both
multi-level regression analysis in sem
we use the data from the city also to
perform a criterion and validation and
refine our model ok we have 74
participants you can see the
participation by clinic varied widely we
had a couple of large clinics the PCPs
you can see were the hubs within the
clinic and collaborations outside it was
a little more diverse but still the PCPs
are pretty involved ok so these clinics
also took the equation staff
questionnaire which looks at adaptive
reserve other things and they took the
collaborative practices assessment tests
and so for example on the results of
that who the gap have the highest result
ok and then clinic see had the
second-highest result we can rank them
so this shows the rankings on the CSU
and the CP 80 and their rankings for
each of our factors and the reason I
show them separately scar factors are
different behaviors you can't compare
them and if you look at it there's a
reason to get correlation between an
effect is ninety percent spearmint on
the c SQ the cpt and the trust factor it
falls down significantly we look at the
other behaviors this makes sense you
think about what the studies do because
the CSU and cbt look at things like how
much you trust the people you're working
with some of the questions they ask you
know it's more general factors
okay we looked at the model again and
because we have more data we could
refine it we were able to add looking at
the effects of collaboration managers
changes in roles and changes and rolls
didn't have a significant effect on
perceived collaboration variables we
took a look at this is combining data
from two studies on the association
between the increase in collaboration
behave channel usage with the increase
in collaboration behaviors a single
arrow means double arrows means both
studies found this relationship one
study means just one hourlies one study
found it a dot means nobody no
relationship was that was sickness I'll
talk about a second testalex inhibited
and it down means it was actually
negatively correlated that increase in
this channel resulted in a decrease my
car was associated with a decrease in
that collaboration behavior as you can
see in formal communications ie being
co-located helped across the board we
had something they were detrimental
faxes for example ended up a decrease in
perceived communication sandy needs our
progress note this was interesting a
decrease in trust that could be over
written if you sent a message or a flag
saying okay look at what I'm sending you
here's what to focus on and in fact that
note could be very helpful for
adaptation behaviors multidisciplinary
meetings proved to be effective in most
situations the same three topics came in
our open ended distance time in the EHR
with similar effects and so with more
data we could actually do more analysis
one of the issues we had is some things
were significant one study in another
I'm not sure whether it was because I
was underpowered looking at after the
fact my posterior power was only about
fifty three percent and hope for a
higher abla Katie and it also could be
due
not to the significance but just a
cultural invitation effects that the way
you implement in each are the culture
bill of the clinic also makes a
difference so analysis of all three
datasets says that collaboration
behaviors are distinct you can have one
without the other but it doesn't
indicate how effective they'll be not
being combined there are studies that
show that collaboration does have
benefits but it takes more time what's
the balance yang what collaborates you
need win okay colocation proves
collaboration that's just a factor but
most practices can't afford to have all
the specialists on site they need our
Dina suggested the HR can start to help
the bridge the gap if it's used as a
messaging in a coordinator but also
suggest that the HR poor performance it
makes things worse similar would wear an
MP found okay connections complained
about the EHR but in our first study the
quality is setting nobody wanted to go
back and the open-ended comments from
phase 2 and phase 3 were positive about
the hrs role in collaboration questions
not to get rid of EHR but how do we make
it better work I'd like to do going
forward is look at the effects of
collaboration behaviors on patient and
process outcomes examine how the
implementation processes enhancer affect
the club collaboration behaviors and
finally how do we set up a methodology
for actually actually evaluating
technology tools looking at how they
bridge distance attire so HR is here
it's a city of an actor we need to keep
improving it we now have a tool I think
we can use to try and monitor how are we
doing in that improvement process and
this will law clinics to evaluate the
interventions they're doing including
the east of the HR and finally if we can
increase the effective the HR we can
help me its potential for improving
triple-a out
comes patient satisfaction and
effectiveness the last four years have
been for me The Times frustrated
journaling very good and I'm very
appreciative all the help I've gotten
from people at ohsu I mean david has put
up with a lot and I appreciate it and
give me pretty constant and helpful
guidance and the top net teams also been
very helpful I thank you for your help I
see them in the back dr. ash has been a
matter as well and very valued the poet
team great especially my cohort in crime
on some of the interviews adam wright
and jen hall devi of course was also on
that team Debbie Cohen remember my
committee she set up some forward
experiences Leo the Richmond clinic I
actually carried forward into this and I
appreciate it Gary Olsen was generous
and sharing what the work he was doing
on the collaboration wizard is also on
my committee I'd net took the notes at
the RIP meeting has helped me along the
way to gorman you get the problem i'll
go over and gets the for a lot of the
initial formative stuff he was a big
help there and then on the other end
racial dress Peck has been helpful to me
and rewriting the articles device has
been a great environment to work in I
appreciate the staff the faculty and my
fellows fellows we're lucky here then
we've got a great library and I've
gotten a lot of help librarians here at
ohsu and also somewhat psu I'm very
grateful for that and finally this is
all possible to the National Library of
Medicine funded under a training grant
and I'm grateful for that so with all
that gratitude I thank you and I'm sure
you got questions
we are streaming this of press the
button down the little red light comes
on Dr Fletcher
honestly I was surprised at these a
couple things I was surprised at the
strength of the Association we found
between the flags and notes and theme
actually the difference that could make
an adaptive behaviors I was also a
little bit surprised that sending a note
had a negative effect on its own that's
surprised I was obviously prize cuz i
was initially a goof length scale and
i'm also a little bit disappointed from
the sign of the effects when we looked
at the model including the care managers
that there's some frustration in those
relationships Nathan um how do you
define communication and do you think it
would be worthwhile to make a
distinction between different types of
communication one way versus two way or
ok so the communication factor is
actually looking at it in terms of
questions we asked were and the first
one was how often do you get the
information you need to care for your
common patient from your collaborator
the second question this actually I
change in the development process
because was originally a mirror was how
often does time prevent you from giving
the information your collaborator needs
and the third was how aware are you of
what your collaborator is doing with
your patient so we have those three
questions those three made up the factor
yeah and it's it was interesting because
before I added the time I always get the
information but once you mentioned time
people normalize it people started
giving me a spread of data that was
worthwhile and I didn't have with the
coordination and with the adaptation
questions can you talk a little bit more
about the data types that you used did
you consider the data as ordinal
categorical that's that that is a really
good question in a part of ongoing
debate within the statistical community
the data I collected is obviously
ordinal data with on the survey okay and
there are two camps one says that
ordinal data forget it it's subjective
you can't use it go away go bother me
another camp which is a camp to try and
subscribe in which i've seen some useful
research court says ordinal data can be
usable if it has a wide enough range of
values and if the distribution is such
that it approximates a normal
distribution so that before i could use
this data as regular normally
distributed data I actually had to run
tests you know look Shapiro and kamagra
note to try and make sure I had a normal
distribution and when I did that I found
the trustee that did not fill that
requirement which is why I ended up
dividing it into categoric available
variable with three values and it's your
question
okay dr. Hirsch interesting so um well I
was intrigued by your comment at the end
maybe not a treat the but just tying
this to outcome so that that makes a lot
of sense for future research you know
seeing how well collaboration
communication influence outcomes does it
looks like your data your instruments
kind of give you some sort of overall
measure does your do your instruments
allow you to actually tease out specific
things so you know maybe you know this
clinic has lesser collaboration although
maybe they communicate better so that
you could start to maybe develop some
hypotheses on kind of future work of you
know if we make this intervention to
help them communicate better this will
lead to better outcomes exactly your so
I what dr. Hirsch Barnes who you're
saying is the fact that we have
different behavior factors if you will
means that we can always have to take a
look and see which of the behaviors is
necessary to achieve better outcomes
rather than just saying the coop whether
collaboration necessary and I think
that's absolutely right and in fact but
the data also one of the reasons I did
something different is I actually asked
for going and coming and normally you
don't do that normally ask about going
only because it's harder to evaluate or
coming only is because these
relationships are often asymmetrical for
example a care manager is more likely to
change their schedule and coordinate
than a provider and it's important to
look at the symmetry begin those
behaviors too so yes what you're saying
is absolutely right and I think it'd be
fascinating to look at how these changes
in patterns affect outcomes in process
efficiency so okay I mean I just want to
clarify so I mean you you your
instruments will give you the ability to
measure specific aspects of those things
or your instrument does give you that
does or doesn't absolutely it does and I
would argue that it actually cannot be
used as a total score
because you can't add apples and
Chevrolets just won't work and that's
what we have for collaboration behaviors
Danny of it I'm carrying out a question
you already answered my question dr.
Cohen you do any you know comparison of
different institutions and in I mean so
you've got four different measures
basically so you know how what are your
thoughts on not necessarily how to
combine them into one number but how to
look at them you know as a whole and
then you know compare one one group or
once institution to another sort of
looking forward towards using it to
correlate with outcomes the problem is
i'm not sure that increased adaptation
is always a good thing it takes a lot of
time to tailor a plan and if you look at
people are doing bundles what they're
actually doing is they're doing
coordination on a huge scale but it's
pretty much let's call it evidence-based
God guideline-based practice as opposed
to tailored practice I think it's up to
the air whether or not that's an
important question I think it's up in
the air how much time we want to spend
when I send something two radiologists
how much of a reporter I want to give
them to be effective and efficient
probably more than we're giving them now
but not and so what I'm saying is we can
give the reports of the behaviors but
I'm not sure that you can see that
there's one standard it's going to apply
to everybody and you're not I'm sorry
your clinic is not at the gold standard
dr. Cohen I can't do that I don't think
we've got the evidence stewed at this
point yeah I wasn't suggesting that as
much as maybe there are combinations of
profiles that might be more associated
with certain outcomes or others not
necessary
more of everything is better but some
some mixtures might be more effective
than other mixture I think that's cool I
haven't looked at it that is a cool idea
and I don't have an updated to do it
here but I really yeah that could be an
interesting that's added that to the
list other questions
and you're still awake I'm bro Laura um
this is your work is fascinating across
several disciplines I'm interested in
knowing if you have already been in
contact with different groups that look
at quality improvement in the health
care system as well as organizations
that deal with organizational behavior
because I think that this study would be
of interest to both sets of those
peoples I haven't well I mean just
trying to get my dissertation done thank
you thank you all for coming have a good
day as we said we need to the committee
needs to stay everybody else if you can
just take your conversations outside be
very helpful to us okay so thank you
thank bill thank you for everything